[Music]
without a doubt the most depicted figure
in art is jesus paintings stained glass
mosaics i'm sure you've seen them all
before but what about this one a
disturbing image of jesus as a
three-headed hybrid a strange
multi-headed being with one body three
noses and four eyes these images are so
weird in fact that they were even banned
by the catholic church
perhaps because they stem from ancient
pagan mythologies or that they appear in
portraits of the devil welcome to
strange christian art
this episode
three-headed jesus
how did this unusual depiction of jesus
come about and what does it even mean
well it's all to do with illustrating a
core christian idea about god the
trinity it's the idea that god exists as
three distinct persons the father the
son and the holy spirit christians
believe that all of them are god yet
simultaneously the father is not the son
the son is not the spirit and the spirit
is not the father confused yes that's
normal it's a confusing idea that defies
logic but maybe that's the point and for
centuries people have argued over what
it does and does not mean and if you're
an artist tasked with representing all
this you're faced with a bit of a
problem how do you make this diagram
into a nice painting some artists have
tried to depict the trinity as three men
of the same appearance but then you risk
implying that you're worshipping three
gods an idea known as tritheism and if
you paint just one of the divine persons
then you could be accused of ignoring
the other two to get around these
problems artists found an ingenious
loophole to combine them all together as
a result you get this an amalgamation of
the three divine persons into one being
whilst it's an orthodox design it's
pretty orthodox religiously speaking it
roughly manages to capture the idea that
god is three divine persons in one oh
and to be clear this is not what god is
supposed to look like it's more of a
symbolic representation
at least i hope this method of combining
figures together has led to some pretty
fascinating artworks take a look at the
6th century icon of jesus incidentally
it's one of the oldest depictions of him
around now if you look closely you'll
notice that each side of the face looks
ever so slightly different one half
looks quite stern and the other is more
gentle if i mirror the sides for you
you'll get a better idea of what i mean
it's believed that this half represents
his divine nature with him pointing up
to heaven the other half is his human
nature with his gospel book for the
people on earth despite these very
clever paintings by imaginative artists
depicting jesus or god with 100
theological accuracy is a bit of a
tricky task the fact is these religious
doctrines don't translate well onto
canvas as doing so often results in
confusion this has led many to simply
give up trying or even ban figurative
depictions of god entirely
[Music]
returning now to our beautifully strange
three-headed jesus this kind of image
has its roots in a number of ancient
mythologies take the roman god janus as
an example he's the patron deity of time
new beginnings and change to symbolize
this he has one face looking forwards
and the other looking backwards you may
be aware that the month of january is
named after him a time when one is
looking at the year ahead and the year
just passed going further back and we
have the celtic god lugus
in irish mythology he is a warrior deity
and is associated with law and kingship
this stone carving from ancient france
dates back to 200 bce despite looking
like jesus it predates christianity by a
few centuries there are plenty of these
three-headed deities to be found from
the slavic god triglav whose heads
symbolize the sky earth and the
underworld to hecate the greek goddess
of sorcery and magic
of course there are many outside of
europe too particularly in hindu
traditions with the god brahma the
three-headed divinity of creation
three-headed deities were surprisingly
commonplace and it's believed that when
christianity started to spread in europe
it began absorbing the various artistic
motifs that were used to depict these
pre-existing gods they provided the
necessary inspiration for early
christian artists who were having a
tough time depicting the trinity
[Music]
by the middle ages and early renaissance
our three-headed jesus was a
well-established art form in fact it's
everywhere appearing in the unlikeliest
of places in some manuscripts he has a
branching neck that sprouts three
hydra-like heads in others he has one
head but the faces are fused together in
some cases it's just a floating
disembodied head
they may seem strange to us today but in
medieval europe it was widely accepted
perhaps it's because there was a
fascination with all things
unexplainable and otherworldly in the
medieval imagination there seemed to be
a connection between the distorted and
the divine
although three heads were a popular way
to imagine god it also became a way of
imagining his counterpart the devil in
dante's inferno an epic description of
hell and its various circles satan is
also described as having three heads all
three are consuming the bodies of
infamous traitors deep in the frozen
center of the inferno dante's chilling
description was enormously influential
in how artists began to envision satan
there are so many illustrated copies of
dante's inferno that have these
disturbing sketches all of a
three-headed devil
[Music]
due to their growing association with
satan and monsters these three-headed
jesus's became controversial to use
soon religious thinkers called out
against them one of the earliest
examples was sin antoninus of florence
who said that they were quote monstrous
in the nature of things and despite
their original good intention to
illustrate the holy trinity eventually
they were banned entirely in 1628 pope
urban vii outlawed the practice of
depicting god with three heads to
replace them came other more soothing
representations of the trinity often in
paintings that depicted the father as an
elderly man the son is jesus and the
holy spirit as a dove to this day this
motif has become the industry standard
however the practice of depicting jesus
with three heads didn't go away entirely
you see as christianity spread beyond
the borders of europe into the americas
these paintings began to resurface
this painting comes from cusco peru and
was made sometime in the mid 18th
century it's believed that it was used
as a visual teaching aid made by spanish
missionaries to convert the indigenous
inca population you can see it's a
teaching tool he's even holding up the
diagram from before considering that the
image of a three-headed god was
originally adopted by christianity it
seems that we've come full circle now
it's been used by christians to convert
non-christians
from an ancient mythological trope to a
christian symbol to an object of fear
the three-headed jesus has a long
multi-faceted journey to have got here i
certainly think it's one of the most
peculiar images to have come out of this
religion in some ways it's a useful
visual tool to explain the concept of
the trinity the paradoxical idea that
one god exists as three whilst these
images may seem strange to us now it was
once regarded as a sacred icon nowadays
things that don't conform to our visual
standards are often rejected liminal
beings that break the rules of our
natural world
yet there was a time when things that
couldn't be explained through logic were
seen as divine and miraculous that's why
to a secular person like me early art
like this is still so fascinating it
goes against modern aesthetic standards
finding beauty in the bazaar and we've
only just scratched the surface it's
just one of many examples of strange
christian
[Music]
art hey thanks for watching i had a
great time making this video and i'm
looking forward to making more like this
if you like this video and want to see
more why not subscribe a like and a
comment also go a really long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time goodbye